I think india has a very good chance of
becoming a superpower simply by the fact
that its diverse population its
diversity knowledgebase education levels
people's IT skills that have been shown
around the world the medical facilities
that are available in a medical field
that has reached around the world has
has taken India to do already what it is
today and I think if that is that that
skill those skills are home in this
education and by educating as many of
its population as possible I think India
can easily become a superpower it has
the financial means and it has the
education of you know the base that
requires I think india in the next 15
years is a line to reach that level
easily